of the ones who do have this natural
talent what do you think it is that gets
in the way
besides the the discipline and the and
the time that they're willing to put in
or is that it right there they're not
willing to work on honing they're not
willing to put in the time that it takes
they have brilliant ideas but as I've
discussed in other places and in other
Ruth other videos the most overrated
part of the screenplay equation is the
idea ideas are really pretty useless and
worthless again
give me a repeating myself but I am a
one of those people who believes that
Breaking Bad is one of the greatest
achievements in the history of
civilization I think it's really great
great drama so what's the idea that
drives it a high school chemistry
teacher gets a cancer diagnosis and so
he decides to go into the
methamphetamine trade with an
incorrigible former student of his a
criminal you know to sell drugs to
support his family that is the stupidest
idea I've ever heard many many companies
shot that down and yet it is this
triumphant achievement 62 hours of a TV
series every frame of which is engaging
and and and captivating and involving
and the so how did that happen the
answer is they told a good story it's
where the story it's really all about
story that's what we believe at UCLA
that's that's what I believe a few years
I mean imagine if somebody came up to
you and and said I have an idea for a
movie
this guy's stutters but he has to give a
speech so he hires a speech therapist
they work on the species gives a speech
at the end of the movie if somebody told
you that that's gonna win the Oscar for
Best Picture and Best Screenplay you
figure they're crazy and yet that is of
course the King's Speech
and again I think it just demonstrates
the the value of story and the value
lessness of ideas and I think that very
young people are more into ideas they
have great ideas I like to say when you
have a great idea if you have a really
really great idea for a screenplay
that's all you've got I mean what
remains after that everything the
characters have to be invented the
dialogue they speak has to be created it
has to be punchy and peppy and
provocative and pungent I'm just getting
into peas now and poetic and it has to
be worth listening to all for itself
just because there's something kind of
charming about it but beyond that it
camp being just for itself it also has
to advance the story in a palpable
measurable identifiable way likewise
expand the audience's appreciation of
the characters it takes time for me to
give you an idea about a movie I can you
know takes a handful of seconds to walk
you through the story of the movie who
takes to the length of the movie a
couple of hours so that's where the
value is
you